افادت وسائل الاعلام الروسيه عن وقوع
انفجار في منطقه سركيف باساد التي تبعد
حوالي سبعين كيلو مترا شمال شرق موسكو
اشاره المعلومات الاوليه الى ان الانفجار
وقع في مصنع زاكورس الذي يصنع معدات تصوير
ومراقبه واجهزه طبيه ومخباريه منذ عام
1935 ولم تعرف اسباب الانفجار او حجم
الاضرار الناجمه عنه وقد اخلت السلطات
الروسيه مصنع زاكورس بالكامل واجلت السكان
في محيطه هذا نقله وكاله التاسعه عن خدمات
الطوارئ الروسيه ان الانفجار في مصنع
زاكورس في موسكو ليس ناتجا عن هجوم بطائره
مسيره
للمتابعه مع معنا من موسكو مراسله الجزيره
رانيا اذا الهجوم ليس بطائره مسيره فما
اسبابه هل اتضحت حتى الان
حتى هذه اللحظه سهام يعني لا معطيات فيما
يتعلق باسباب وقوع هذا الانفجار الانفجار
الذي وصفته السلطان المحليه بالانفجار
الكبير نعم وزاره الطوارئ او هيئات
الطوارئ تتحدث عن ان الانفجار نجمه يعني
عن حادث داخلي ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه سهام
لم تصدر تصريحات رسميه تؤكد ان ما حدث هو
يعني نتيجه لاحداث داخليه تماس كهربائي او
ما الى ذلك ام ان هذا الانفجار نشم عن
يعني اعمال تخريبيه او هجوم بمثيرات وما
الى ذلك حتى هذه اللحظه المعلومات حول
اسباب هذا الحادث الشحيحه للغايه وفقا
للتصريحات الصادره حتى هذه اللحظه فان
الهيئات الامنيه المعنيه كانت قد وصلت الى
مكان الانفجار تجري عمليات التحقيق في
الحادث هذا الحادث سهام الذي يعني حتى هذه
اللحظه وفقا للمعطيات الاوليه يعني تسبب
عصابه احد عشر شخصا وايضا تمت اتخاذ قرار
الاجلاء الكامل لكل يعني السكان في منطقه
هذا الانفجار اود الاشاره لان هذا المصنع
الذي يدعى مصنع زاكورس هذا المصنع هو مصنع
للبصريات اي انه معني بصناعه العدسات
المخصصه لاجهزه التصوير والمراقبه للمعدات
الطبيه والمخباريه وما الى ذلك هذا المصنع
يعمل منذ عام
1935 وبالفعل هذا الانفجار يعني يعني اود
التذكير الى ان هذا المصنع يقع في منطقه
التي تبعد نحو 70 كيلومترا عن العاصمه
موسكو بالفعل هذا الانفجار ضخم هو الاول
من نوعه في مصنع في هذا الحجم وهذه
الاهميه ولكن سهام بالفعل الاهم حاليا هو
النظر في اسباب هذا الانفجار التي لم تتضح
خلال يعني حتى هذه اللحظه ولكن يعني في ظل
ما نشه حاليا من هجمات متكرره بالمسيرات
التي تطال مختلف المنشات المدنيه ليس فقط
في ضواحل العاصمه موسكو والمناطق الحدوديه
بل وايضا في العاصمه موسكو نفسها اود
الاشاره الى ان هذا الحادث تزامن ايضا مع
هجوم بمثيرات احبطته القوات
الروسيه وزاره الدفاع اشاره الى مسيرتين
صباح هذا اليوم هاجمه العاصمه موسكو وتم
اسقاطها بواسطه انظمه الدفاع الجوي في
ضواحي العاصمه موسكو قبل الوصول للعاصمه
وعليه لابد من الانتظار قليلا سهام لطرد
الصوره اكثر حول اسباب وحيثيات هذا
الانفجار نعم من الحيفيات الوارده حتى
الان ان الاصابات بلغت حتى الان 11 مصابا
في الانفجار الذي وقع بمصنع زاكورس كان
هناك ايضا عند النفي عن موضوع المسيرات
وهل استخدمت او لم تستخدم لكنه ايضا جاء
في ظل الحديث ايضا عن استهدافات متواصله
في موسكو
للجانب الاوكراني يتهم بها الجانب
الاوكراني اذا اردنا ان
نفهم طبيعه
المنطقه التي وقع فيها الحادث بالنظر الى
الاستهدافات السابقه هي بعيده يعني هل هذا
يعزز هذه المعلومات الاوليه بانه لم
تستهدف من الجانب الاوكراني
بدايه عبد السلام هذه المنطقه هي منطقه
سياحيه تضم العديد من المناطق والمعالم
الاثريه والسياحيه في روسيا هي بالفعل
مركز سياحي ان صح التعبير يعني فضلا عن
ذلك هذا المصنع ايضا يحمل اهميه كبيره نحن
نعلم ان هذا المصنع
يعمل منذ عام 1500
1935 اي من دون الاتحاد منذ العهد
السوفيتي السابق وهو معني بصناعه العدسات
هذه العدسات يعني لا تستخدم فقط في المجال
الطبي والمخبري وما الى ذلك بل ايضا هي
يعني تستخدم لاجهزه المراقبه اي الحديث قد
يدور عن اجهزه المراقبه التي قد تستخدم من
قبل القوات المسلحه الروسيه اذا يعني
بالفعل يعني مثل هذا الاستهداف في منطقه
مهمه سياحيا هذا المصنع الذي يقوم بتصنيع
ادوات مهمه بما في ذلك لاجهزه المراقبه
والتصوير اذا هناك ما ان كان هذا الحادث
بالفعل نجم عن عطل داخلي عن تماس كهربائي
وماء وما الى ذلك ام انه يعني قد تم
مهاجمته بمسيارات ولكن بالفعل نحن حاليا
سلام ندخل في اطار التنبؤات كونه رسميا
حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتم الاعلان عن الاسباب
وحيثيات هذا الحادث ولكن بالفعل في ظل
الهجمات المتكرره في ظلم نشهده حاليا في
العاصمه موسكو وضواحيها بالفعل هناك
تساؤلات ما ان كان هذا الحادث قد نجم عن
استهداف سواء بمسيرات او يعني قيام مجموعه
تقريبيه بالقيام بخطوات معينه لتفجير هذا
المصنع وما الى ذلك وعليه نحن بالفعل يعني
تزامن كل هذه الاحداث يثير تساؤلات ما ان
كان هناك ضلوع للجانب الاوكراني في هذا
الحادث ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه كما قلت هذا
كله ياتي في طارق النبويه مثل النبؤات
سلام دعنا ننتظر الروايه الرسميه الروسيه
حول
هذا الانفجار وملابساته شكرا لك رانيا
الدريدي كنت